[Musik]
dort wird präsentiert von toyota hybrid
braucht keine steckdose und fährt
trotzdem elektrisch
[Musik]
der frühling trägt den zauber der
lebensfreude in sich getragen von der
suche nach inspirationen besuchten
gartenfreunde ausstellungen doch die
idylle ist zerbrechlich
dann nämlich wenn man glaubt dass nicht
die schnecken die größten schädlinge
sind sondern die nachbarn man zb das
nachbargrundstück gegangene pflegt es
ist uns das herz gebrochen als diese
fielen bäume abgeholzt wurden danach bot
stören juni ist mit dem revolver von
bach und hat man früher mir werden zu
diesem recht hoch und so sprach dieser
film erzählt in vier geschichten wie
kleine paradiese zur hölle werden
[Musik]
deren spuren eine förderung mit
irgendwem der nachbarn zum beispiel dann
ist das für mich die beste therapie zum
stammspieler
[Musik]
um sich zu ärgern muss der emeritierte
professor für angewandte physik nicht
weit gehen
da sagt der fichte ja als zwei
krankenkassen emittiert hans-peter sturm
ganz voll platz bis hin zur türe mit die
ihre nase lieber dixie und nach hannover
die aus holz k
und ich hatte am nachmittag sei das
allemal
sie sind sind eigene warenbestand flagge
aber so schlimm nicht dass ich meine
beiden anbieter sind ja gut aber sie
schlagen will ich nach jedem windstoß
hat mal wieder messe bozen hat und das
ist mir sie sind ja die bauern fällt
jetzt müssten sie eigentlich hatte sie
oder ist gar nicht meine intention sind
dass du alles kahl geschlagen wird
sondern dass einfach die franken beim
saniert werden und ersetzten die
hochstammbäume ich mich letztlich
interessiert andere gute texte und
umwelt mit einfachen wir totalen
kahlschlag später schrecklich waren sie
dachte 20 jahre mit meiner frau die dem
oster und dem händler 25 jahre
kursverhältnis kam mit der nachbarschaft
in der letzten drei jahre ich hoffe für
im dach zwischen peter schreck und ernst
bucher herrscht eiszeit
die beiden reden nicht miteinander wenn
sie jetzt nur gedenkt sehen sie nach
denen abgründigkeit sich sehr gut aus
die wollen wirklich nicht lange haltbar
wäre und den heim müssen schilderte
machen nicht den kann hier mal mehr
reklamieren alter herr bucher nicht und
denn nicht da ist ja super sache und
wenn wir den tag gibt es da eine neue
pflanze schon mit der stadt abgesprochen
ist nebst den gefällten bäumen gibt es
noch weitere gründe die den konflikt
befeuern
gibt es denn überhaupt die möglichkeit
sich wieder schön nach hits versöhne mit
dem nachbarn ja bis jetzt sind die
möglichkeiten gescheitert
was hat sie dazu bei dass das wirklich
friede ist jetzt viel habe mich einfach
nackt und deswegen verurteilt wurde
wieder das land da zu einem
schleuderpreis kauft hat der burg
behauptet dass sie das grundstück wo
jetzt das steht für einen spottpreis der
frauen auftreten ja das ist so eine in
österreich wurde herr blocher macht
wählen einfach nicht verbreitet das ist
nicht einfach auf täter tatsächlich aber
dass das land zwei monate lang ein
käufer gesucht und verschiedene niveau
in 30 km
denn das nicht gemacht hat und mährische
a porter worte und mir hat einfach seit
jahren mit und zwar zu den
privatverkäufen würde nicht zu dem mir
bestimmt tatsächlich wollte auch ernst
bucher die gartenparzelle kaufen aber
nun gehört sie architekt schreck er
lässt auf dem ehemaligen schrebergarten
ein haus errichten
das wiederum passt bucher nicht er
beschimpfte seinen widersacher per e
mail
das ergibt sich roboter logisch belastet
hier gibt es wirklich franken ab
ohne saft verhalten turbo will die
eigentlich schon irgendwie geschafft hat
der geniale schikanieren in meinen augen
ist das psychisches problem
christliche schlage zweifel
beleidigungen und beschimpfungen die das
licht einfach nur immer drin im januar
dieses jahres mussten am bezirksgericht
kreuzlingen die schimpftiraden beurteilt
werden
die verhandlung endete mit einem
schuldspruch für ernst
wegen übler nachrede muss er eine busse
von 300 franken bezahlen
zu seinen lasten gehen auch schrecks
anwaltskosten das sind weitere 3800
franken
dass man mit begriff für buchloe
herabsetzt und natürlich geld woanders
portal exklusiv punkt licht und dom ich
verurteilt wurde weil ich genau wie
begriff covern er benutzte mirasol
verletzend erachtet habe in dem
konkreten fall ist es um den begriff
geld gegangen
nein der hamburger hätte sich nur müssen
entschuldigen denn wer gar nicht
passiert dennoch eine gar kreis
verfahren am hals meinte dazu
aufgefordert das internet welle
das heißt dass er selber zuschreiben
[Musik]
interesse dass jetzt wieder zu wollen so
daran sich ungerecht finde aber ich find
die reguläre vorsorglich haben
das ist nicht meine intention und ich
habe etwas halt die rockmesse schlucken
der konflikt im blumenweg quartier ist
trotz des gerichts entscheides nicht
gelöst das werden die weiteren
ereignisse noch zeigen
[Musik]
roland brunner wurde sie dem 86 jährigen
und seinen hügeln juli hat der senat
darüber dass vermutlich in die zweite
luft wachsen zwei buben sind
mittlerweile 20 und 21 und zieht ins
trainingscamp die höhner familie und
gibt dir und wir sind richtig die haie
und füllt ist da wohl auch rambo ist
hier zu hause
der zwerg kam ist in dieser geschichte
der übeltäter andere halten einen
wachhund roland brunner hat rambo eine
familie vor allem in yamada ich halte
die höhner familie zement viele
niedrigen die vormonate bussard habe ich
mit einer frau die jungen hören gern
wiederholen wenn es zu ruhig ist er dort
alarm schlug
und der sorgt für honig und der chef der
chef vor der ganzen familie rambo ist im
ganzen quartier bekannt denn er ist
unüberhörbar es gestärkt
also nerv der dich nervt der gute idee
nach toyota motor zu ziehende vögel
stören
warum sollte er mehr steiner gehört dazu
der natur wir leben hier auf dem land
und er gehört einfach dazu und es ist
auch schön wenn der sonnenaufgang auf
geht oder wenn es zum tag kommt dass er
gut angefühlt
aber nicht alle sind so glücklich wenn
der decke gehüllt ein nachbar erhob den
mahnfinger drohte mit konsequenzen
vor der kamera bilder senior keine
stellung nehmen er sei massiv beschimpft
worden nachdem er im regionalfernsehen
seinem ärger luft gemacht hatte da kommt
viel jetzt bis zum city wo probleme
beschäftigen
vielleicht ist das problem
das ist das große problem ist aber der
amazone 3 und da ist das erlaubt hier
noch vor fünf jahren störte sich der
anwohner zum ersten mal am schreihals
von nebenan
damals war noch nicht am bau der hahn im
korb sondern dessen vorgänger aber auch
er war kein bisschen leiser zum
leidwesen des nachbarn jetzt karriere
recht in frieden trägt damit der senat
aber frau und ich denke mein trainer
schlichte zwar klagt der regenfälle in
torgau und den hat man denn der harte
tour der kopf abgeschnitten
und wisst ihr wieder ein junge nach
hause und das hat der direktor der neue
haben war dann rambo und mit ihm ging
das kikeriki weiter der fall landete vor
dem bezirksgericht dieses entschied der
hahn darf bleiben
er muss sich allerdings anders nachtruhe
gesetz halten die stars wie sie wie
solid schaltuhr und vorschriften
ausgangssperre hat vom gegen 22 uhr bis
morgen am 7 mit den extra so installiert
für chemiker schuf das der liebe herr
nachbar den hausfrieden ist und der
könnte es nicht voran 57 ideen ins freie
liste mit
heute morgen schon morgen 60 mit heilig
und drängt natürlich ein bisschen dauern
endlich mal dass der earl of god seiten
gehören immer noch etwas isoliert
schallisoliert oder schreie morgen so
dass die schöne nachwuchs vor dem gipfel
selbst die unglücke und die glocke ohne
der gipfel war das war mir glück nicht
da ist das wunderbar signatur dass er
glücklich aus drei projekte also das
familienglück mit der familie wieder
friedlich zusammen mit nachbarn herbei
ich bin nicht den schritt an ich bin
einfach für friede und einklang und dem
was will denn wenn das wetter mache der
hahnenkampf könnte tatsächlich in die
nächste runde gehen und brunner sagt der
nachbar habe gedroht den fall bis vor
bundesgericht zu ziehen
[Musik]
klagen über lärm sind der ehemaligen
gerichtspräsidentin andrea staubli
wohlbekannt staubli ist heute
präsidentin des schweizerischen
dachverbandes für mediation lärm grund
die nachbarschaftskonflikt sehr häufig
vor
und wahrscheinlich muss man einfach
sagen es sind hüter unserer gesellschaft
so lärm bereits überflutet das mit sehr
sensibel reagiert man aber immer noch
offen an und das machen wir nicht
weniger lieder auch im blumenweg
quartier am bodensee wird es schon bald
enger werden das heißt die miese
stimmung zusätzlich an
da schon gefällte bäume anlass zum
streit gaben
[Musik]
im petersch rix garten ragt einbau
profil in den himmel
was einige anwohner empört aber der
reihe nach
der architekt hat kurz vor seiner
pensionierung große pläne
das problem hätte ein restaurant wo wir
das projekt geplant wo mir ist ein täter
hand aufs alter dieses haus zu ersetzen
und doch ein neubau machen wo einfach
kalt verdichtete bauen
dort entsprechen und wo energetisch halt
einfach nachhaltig ist
statt aussicht auf einen garten
plötzlich ein mehrfamilienhaus wurde
nase der 81 jährige ernst bucher hat
seine liebe mühe damit die zukünftige
baustelle liegt ausgerechnet gegenüber
von seinem arbeitszimmer und in diesem
gibt der emeritierte professor für
physik studenten und schülern nachhilfe
unterricht denn da die schwere last
monatelang hin und her vor allem der
bosch und abtransportieren
das neue baumaterial bringen da haben
wir keine geistige produziert das ist
ein grund warum ich den acht personen
nervt das ist eigentlich rücksichtslos
der nacht aber natürlich setze ich muss
was tun
aber es waren dienen können den kampf
nicht dass bohlen gibt ja natürlich aber
er mache das ja in erster linie und non
profit machen einmal was ist so
eigentlich hat ist nicht unbedingt der
fall gewesen ist im alter von 87
name kommerz generiere auf kosten der
lebensqualität
auch sie liegen mit nachbar schreck in
clinch wegen des bauprojektes ines und
bert schlepper erhoben einsprache
nachbar schreck habe ihnen nie gesagt
wie groß der neubau werde ich bin doch
sie übrigens im jahr des herrn mit offen
raunte spielt stehe am anfang einer
zeitlos mit das projekt von ich mach es
ist breiter und flacher und länger als
da wo man hätte ich hätte ich wusste war
dass gott und man kann sich ja auch
nicht alles gefallen lassen
also wir können einfach schlucken das ja
unser zuhause einfach ja einfach sehr
auf ganzer linie
sein sinn sein schönes verliert ja ich
meine hier wird dann eine wand
hochgezogen
ja die einfach nur mal war und die x mas
einfach schon wenn's geht wer will das
schreiner bert schlepper bezahlt der
wegen des verfahrens für anwaltskosten
rund 20000 franken
[Musik]
was ist der grund dass der sicher so
enervierte vielfaches überdimensioniert
und das ist natürlich nur das ist
regelkonform mit dem muss er sich ab der
wie alle anderen auch petra neubauer
über einen umbau oder irgend soll bis
wenn sie ist auch erreicht war nicht
regelkonform ich den einzige chance auf
baubewilligung
zweimal musste er das baugesuch anpassen
die sache ging es vor verwaltungsgericht
dieses wies die beschwerde ab
im sommer ist spatenstich vorfindet hat
sicheres wirkung auf die
nachbarschaftliche beziehung das tier
strapaziert werden dass nachbarn die
sketche mit und das ist ritter füße
schon bald rollen über den schmalen
blumenweg die lastwagen zur baustelle
hinauf zum schrecken der schläfers das
hauptargument dass wir angst um unsere
kinder haben wenn ihr wenn sie nehmen
auf der straße spielen können sondern
dass da eben cluster weise da hoch und
runter gekauft wird wenn sie bauer über
strömte minimal anforderungen entspricht
ist meines erachtens der punkt wo man
mache mit den elektrogeräten muss wo es
betrifft und lösungssuche und den wir ja
auch mal unter ganze konflikt aus dem
weg gegangen den täter eine lösung mit
der awo machen könne lebe www.zoo
geworden und den jetzt sicher auch
weniger gesprochen türen stoßen da war
dabei wird der bloomberg will
schließlich für den schwerverkehr und an
dem sie die kinder und sicherheit also
dass ich jetzt legt sie entstand durch
vom verwaltungsgericht ganz klar zeigt
worte der blumenweg bürgt für alle
gewässer wo da sind und er klagt vor
allem ausbaumöglichkeiten war den
blumenweg noch könnte gemacht werden
das ist
ab so lukas thema zur sicherheit müsste
eigentlich sagen wenn sie die
verhältnisse sorgen die stars die
einzige firma kaspar schläpfer und die
wollten nicht ändern
[Musik]
im quartier konflikt sind berg schlepper
und ernst bucher verbündete geworden
nachdem sich schleppers gegen das
geplante mehrfamilienhaus juristisch
gewehrt haben holte schreck zum
gegenschlag aus dem kleinkrieg zum opfer
fiel unter anderem ein hasenstall der
hasenstall der vitrine standard dauert
lange und ist der führer gange rund um
das wort gibt das lasse sich feiern
könne bewege drin und das ist halt der
grenze aber sich mündlich so abgemacht
sie und dann und den dänischen viborg
standard hat das auch nicht wollen
unterschrieben und somit tarif müsse den
hasenstall zugbauer und grenzabstand
inhaltliche ist mit mit claudia bienek
sie die schaukel ist auch mündlich ab
macht sie das dass ich dir noch über die
grenze kamen
und da ist ja okay ich hatte hier müsse
abbauen und komplette neue messebauer
und auto grenzabstand die alte au vélo
simon gestanden ist und was ich einfach
nur tabellenachter wo der weg permanent
startet das neue wahlrecht
ich kann aber meint geschrieben und seid
sicher ich denke das toleriert das
können sie stahl oder stört mich nicht
als der ausstellung und auch wir sind
jetzt im grundstück stand der schreibt
das einzige team nie verstanden sie aber
was dann langsam näher geregelt werden
müssen zurück wo und wie projekt von
peter bauer hält er es will halt meint
vor ihm verlangt jetzt dass er darauf
stand die halte und dass er sie es nach
baurecht bringen wo im grundbuch als
live mit grundstück betreut wird und sie
dann gemeinsam stück gekauft als das
alles nie ganz mutig nein das war nicht
meine gesteckt die sind ja selber
kollegen oder webseiten ist einfach sie
das ist eine korrekte was er als boxerin
und den sind zu falco prüfen und den
heinz feststeht dass keine einzige maße
stundenpläne wenn er gemacht hätte
zeichnete sich die kampfzone weitet sich
immer mehr aus
mittlerweile verweigert schreckt den
schleppers dass fahrwege recht über sein
grundstück des - vater und die letztes
jahr machen das user miteinander halt
meter auf der weg offen was andere meter
auf dem grundstück ist und das stellt
anscheinend risse problem da usa droht
wurde mit show mit der besitz clark wenn
wir das wieder hin wäre mache mir mehr
das war eine woche und das ist ein
unding siviglia der stelle wo der
schleppt man mit dem auto hinter user
vor ort und jedes london die ehre
das verbiete sie ihm warum eigentlich
warum was ihm das verbieten das ganz
einfach
er versucht wie es rechts beschreiben
kann also auch diesen bau zu verhindern
er mag die sprache klage schrieb briefe
beschäftigen
beleidigungen und irgendwann ich hatte
einfach mal ein punkt reicht um sich
fertig da süßes da stieß du eine stufe
sei recht denn lass es auch
das ganze team hinter gerade 100 hand
oder das trifft den nagel auf den kopf
einige händler mit zwei erwachsenen und
vier kinder sondern man muss extrem da
und sie sind dann weißt du ja ich werde
ein super tag
und die moral dieser geschichte
gerichte können urteile sprechen
behörden vorschriften erlassen aber
frieden lässt sich nicht verordnen
[Musik]
mein name ist strasser ja der rest der
an der eine 20 jahren gehört der noch an
der nächsten haus kauft dorn die
nachbarschaft drei meter nach poker was
mir finanziell und sich zerstört
dieses haus direkt an einen felsen
gebaut führte giuseppe gras so in den up
kommt das problem seines
mehrfamilienhauses liegt im keller
entlang einer 30 meter langen felswand
tritt an einigen stellen immer wieder
wasser aus das ist eine samstag wo sich
löst durch diese wasser austritt
also dort ist einfach immer wird immer
immer in trockene zieht im sommer vor
allem im winter eignet oder schneit der
nächste felswand woche mit seiner kamera
dokumentiert gras so schon über jahre
hinweg jeden wasser austritt
der hausbesitzer schließt kategorisch
eine natürliche ursache aus
darüber laufen die leitungen brechen und
den kosovo bewässert wird
gute nachbarn das zumindest behauptet
giuseppe gracia oberhalb seines hauses
wohnt der nachbarn
er lehnt ein interview ab seit 15 jahren
schon schwelt der konflikt unzählige
male ging gras so zum anwesen seines
kontrahenten hoch um beweise zu sammeln
das ist eine karte vom ihn noch plakate
wenn er behauptet er muss bewässerung
er macht das sobald ein oder zwei
wunderschön trento metern mit dem fluch
in garsten quellen anschluss das recht
an quellen anschluss und über diese
leitungen laufen circa 15.000 liter
wasser am tag geteilt durch zwei
wasserstelle ein teich und einen brunnen
wo er immer wieder sind gartenschlauch
er werfe die bahn busse die besucher
genauso viel wasser darum lauter wieder
so immer wieder so viel wasser im boden
fließt wächst in bambus
[Musik]
über den fall des gebürtigen italieners
mussten schon bezirksgericht obergericht
und bundesgericht urteilen
sie gaben ihm die richter vollumfänglich
recht hat sie insgesamt weg und sie
konflikt noch gekostet überall millionen
bin halt jetzt weiter
seit drei andere risiken könnten sie
sich denn das alles findet sie wie ein
20 jahre alter landwirt und an die
landschaft
und die
da russ
die mietzinse name
der ton in dieser geschichte in
verstehen sie wird eigentlich die zu
fördern und sage jetzt nicht nur die
panik nur gespielt sitzt nein man kann
nicht auf
ich bin eine wo gerechtigkeit will der
kampf erdgas so aus er sucht sich hilfe
im abklärung und aufnahmezentrum im
kanton thurgau ist das die erste
anlaufstelle für menschen in psychischer
not
sie werden hier in krisen behandelt oder
beraten
psychiaterin elke müller schenkt ihm ein
offenes ohr psychisch welche
auswirkungen haben sie denn ich kann
einfach nicht mehr gut leben immer gut
schlafen meinen lebensinhalt hat sich
nur auf diese geschichte reduziert
ich habe kein interesse
sonst keine befriedigung betriebe kein
hobby mehr kein sport zum mein größtes
hobby war die so wahnsinnig erwählung
das war ein guter ausgleich auch um
stress abzubauen
die zahl fällt mir meine zeit verbringen
mit dieser geschichte klare bin ja nur
unter die leute
die gesellschaft sieht sich mal zurück
auf ja genau so anders wie sieht es mit
familie und partnerschaft ist ein großer
beziehung weil ich nehme mir auch keine
zeit mehr für sie es wäre ja auch eine
option zu sagen ich lasse das hinter mir
und fangen woanders neu an
ja diese option
ja ist nicht ausgeschlossen aber mein
leben mein argument ist nur dieser
dieser geschichte weil ich möchte dass
er mehr gerechtigkeit geschafft wird
menschen können sich verlieren wenn sie
sich ungerecht behandelt fühlen
dann ist der weg in die krankheit nicht
mehr weit sagt psychiater mario
etzelsberger das hätte sich die
bildqualität der psychiatrie aus kohaus
syndrom
wenn die das bestätigt der ort abstrus
übernimmt das man dann ist traumhaft
oder so wirst du immer gott die stadt
übrigens gut zu sich selber und zur
sache und wo nicht dann eben in holz
daher gäbe nur um rache gedroht
[Musik]
peter fabian fi hdr komm mit nach borken
lavendel airport mini-kreisel steve
ressort karwendel käufer ist relevant
fabian neff ist stolzer besitzer von 30
kühe vor drei jahren hatte den hof
seiner eltern übernommen 2013 heiratete
er seine priska seither führen sie in
der siebten generation den betrieb
weiter vor 15 monaten kam laura auf die
welt dann aber wurde das kleine
familienglück getrübt schuld sei der
nachbar von nebenan ein zugezogener aus
dem unterland ist gern etwa 1000 sich
eloquent landschaft wo sie zirkelt er
hält diese aussicht ist nicht nur immer
ganz ruhig und auf dem land aus der geht
einfach nicht auf dem land
ostdeutschland wirtschaft aktiv und
dialekte und da haben wir auch sieht was
einmal die ja forum haustüre laufer
aussieht möglich aufnehmen
[Musik]
die konfliktzone in dieser geschichte
ist ein streifen wiese der zum garten
des nachbarn gehört wird und
hauptsächlich 7 liter hätte ausfüllen
der touristischen opera oder schmeckt
behauptet das will der prestigo also
kühe fressen fressen freitag ein
lavendel also sie sehen den umkreis was
auf der wiese fresse interessiert an
einem sommertag im jahr 2014 verlor der
nachbar dann die nerven dann auch
partner revolver von gartner panama und
hätte ist bedroht das ist höher wenn mir
auf der straße auch höhere preise
betrieb retriever den standard das recht
trocken also sehr wahrscheinlich denkt
der macht faxen und nach arbeitet wird
das magazin zeigt der wolf hatte
eigentlich das sehr ernst die hautfarbe
eine nacht zeit mit der polizei und hat
eine hostie archivbild zufolge mit der
konsequenz sie hätten klar wolf und der
kühlschrank plant die und das ist noch
ein vorgriff ghana schuldig gesprochen
wurde und die zeit als widersacher vor
der kanton über diesen feldweg treiben
die nefs am morgen die kühe auf die
weide weit weg vom haus des nachbarn aus
gutem grund so viel geld dass angst muss
haben sie geschafft dass er weniger zum
strick und
im jahr ich sage jetzt so viele
vielleicht einmal ganz schöne
herbstliche sechs oder sieben mal aber
mehrmals rentiere ganz ihrer auf die
weiter auf dem heimweg müssen die kühe
dann zwangsläufig am garten des nachbarn
vorbei jetzt am fressen fressen vor ohne
nach ufa und so bisschen strom auf super
stoffe wie es vorne noch unbefristet und
wenn du europa her auch wieder richtig
stadträte es ist fünf uhr zum open music
einen lauf für muss sie nicht mehr
springen was sie gratis und für
politisches auch besser wenn es in
arbeit bringen wenn man auch nur ein
acker
wenn dies aber springen also es ist also
unbedingt geriet zwar übertrieben nie
wirklich dass ich einfach rein
funktionär und da auch für die
landschaft würdige gegner haben es mir
nicht anders lösen und so handler wie
mode event in den abendstunden steigt
die anspannung die kühe müssen zurück in
den stall eine große aktion steht an
dass man hören der betriebe und sie
haben es nie geschafft habe ich das
wirklich spannend ist und wirklich
schöne abstand ist das wirklich gut zum
beispiel im jahr nach und das wirklich
geschützt ist
[Musik]
heute hat sich der nachbarn nicht
gezeigt manchmal stehe er jedoch wortlos
neben seinem haus während die kühe
vorbei ziehen sagt fabian es ist einfach
immer warum ist er so schnell nervös
der tiefer liegende grund dieses
konfliktes habe einen allgemeingültigen
charakter erklärt psychiater mario
etzelsberger street sind ganz fertig
grundlage ist dass es mein garten ist
unter anderem andere sim-karte und im
garten darf ich machen was ich wollte
die klinik
und wenn eine prämie beträgt unter dem
ewigen das macht dann muss ich erkläre
und das ist dann der konflikt im normal
psychologische der andere tut mich nicht
respektieren wenn ich ihm sage halt die
höhe zog er sich nicht mal sagen wie man
auch etwas trotzdem und dann hört das
nicht auf die graz verletzung und
steigert sich sohn getötet
im januar 2016 findet die verhandlung
statt am kantonsgericht in st gallen
der beschuldigte erscheint mit seinem
anwalt die beiden zogen nach dem
schuldspruch am kreisgericht dem fall
weiter der rentner will vor der kamera
keine stellung nehmen er scheut dabei
srf dass er mit den nachbarn mehrmals
vergeblich das gespräch gesucht habe die
unterstellung er habe einen revolver
dabei gehabt belaste ihn gesehen habe
dass niemand und die kühe konnten ja
schlecht für ihn aussagen er habe nur
ironisch gefragt ob er die kühe zuerst
erschießen müsse damit sie sich nicht
mehr an seinem garten zu schaffen machen
er habe mit viel zeit seinen garten
gepflegt und empfinde es als leitwerke
rey das nicht dafür gesorgt werden die
kühe von den gräsern blumen und pflanzen
fernzuhalten
ob kühl lavendel fressen oder nicht
konnte der richter während der
verhandlung nicht beurteilen er schlug
den parteien aber eine lösung vor ich
hoffe es gut und er sagt er mache mit
plastikteilen wonach dass die
kirchlichen den rasen gestanden ist und
die hoffen wir so den handwerkerhof
winfried wieder
[Musik]
zwei monate später im märz dieses jahres
das ehepaar neff hat den entscheid des
kantonsgerichts erhalten
der schuldspruch des kreisgerichts wird
bestätigt wegen drohung und
widerhandlung gegen das waffengesetz
wird der nachbar schuldig gesprochen
das kantonsgericht verurteilte den
rentner zu einer bedingten geldstrafe
von 14.000 franken erhalten
wer schlecht machen oder schlecht
behandeln könnte seine arbeit noch ein
bisschen traurig und kein zu sagen aber
so schnell kehrt keine ruhe im ku streit
ein
der nachbar lässt das urteil nicht auf
sich sitzen er teilt srf vor wenigen
tagen mit dass er den fall vor
bundesgericht ziehen werde
zurück in den thurgau wo in diesem haus
der freigelegte felsen im keller
manchmal nass wird
der rechtsstreits kostete giuseppe
grasso bis heute rund 500.000 fanden nur
in einem vorfall aus dem jahr 2005 gab
ihm das obergericht teilweise recht der
nachbar musste ihm 700 franken bezahlen
das ereignis hielt gras wohl mit seiner
kamera fest
damals wurde es erneut nass im keller
auf dem grundstück des nachbars war der
teich durch eis blockiert und schwappte
über
das sei mit ein grund für den tropfenden
fersen gewesen als hauptursache komme
aber schmelzwasser in frage fand der
richter
grasso war mit der begründung nicht
einverstanden und ging vor bundesgericht
ohne erfolg im besitz angeblich neuer
beweise legte er dann beim obergericht
revision ein
das verfahren ist noch nicht
abgeschlossen
ein gutachten von geologe daniel
brüschweiler soll beweisen zu den akten
niederschlag sind und machen wirklich
auch hier ist auf dass es als lokales
problem ist die wall street schnell ganz
schnell wieder
das zeige danke ganz klar dass es in der
lokalen umgebung bis musik und wo nötig
bewachte zone zu hans gestundet und epic
sie wie besessen sammelt giuseppe grasso
messdaten
sie sollen beweisen dass der fels nur
dann tropft wenn der nachbar seinen
garten bewässert und temperaturdaten
sechs daten pro tag 15 jahren vorüber
triffst du sich daten wo nicht einfach
mit unzählige fotos über dem mini
motorräder mal vor überzeugt musik foto
und film
video unter dem video oft & paste gras
so seinen widersacher ab dabei finden
sich die beiden gegenseitig gastmusiker
warum wusste niemand sonderlich und im
teich ins wasser immer auf eine antwort
einmal kam es zu einem leitungs bruch am
hügel oberhalb des grundstücks des
nachbarn kriegs in verschiedene
leitungen
als anhang kanalisationsarbeiten gemacht
wurden kam es zum eklat das so filmte
auf der baustelle obwohl in die gemeinde
ein begehung verbot auferlegt hatte
[Musik]
damit ich keine bewiesen zusammen
im anschluss an diese aufnahmen kam es
zu einem handgemenge gras so und die
arbeiter zeigten sich gegenseitig an
die verfahren sind noch nicht
abgeschlossen der psychiaterin elke
müller erzählt der 54-jährige wie sehr
ihn der vorfall belastet
ich war und beweise sammeln und dann war
da auf dieser bank und dann aber mit
vier mitarbeitern endlich zusammen
gesessen
damit sich die beweise nicht sammeln
kann
ja das war sehr hart verdauen kann kann
ich diese ereignisse ist es etwas was
sie heute noch sehr beschäftigt
aber sie suchen dann diese bilder immer
wieder selber genau sie können innerlich
keinen abstand nehmen ihre normale
übliche arbeit
ich habe nicht ich arbeite nicht mehr
und wieso haben sie nicht mehr
gearbeitet
ich kann mir immer konzentrieren und ich
bin schon immer gereizt sie meinen sie
sind sehr reizbar genau das ding ist sie
schnell aus der bahn werfen genau werden
sie dann auch aggressiv der 54 jährige
hat inzwischen auf anraten der
psychiaterin mit einer therapie begonnen
rechtsberater max im feld hat viel zu
tun mit gras ausfallen
juristische klagen gab es nicht nur
wegen dem wasser problem sondern auch
wegen wiederholter handgreiflichkeiten
im dorf waren von ihnen mit noch bau und
gegenseitig strafe fällig der vorfall im
juli 2014 scherber hofgang also die
bauarbeiter bauer weiter rege sie und
mit einem polizisten beteiligt sind und
alle danach verschiedene
staatsanwaltschaft geführt das heißt
innerhalb dutzend verfahren wirklich
zeit gekauft und bringt das am schluss
im wesentlichen zum schluss werden die
schlimmsten fall gar nie bestraft
und wenn sie jetzt verstanden sich so
wirtschaft signalisiert hat halt mal
umgeschrieben und ordnet alles könnte
zurückziehe und die sache erledigen
wie sehen sie das also bin ich
verstanden dass man die ersten fahrer
karas ist ihre die bringe mir daumen
der anwalt glaubt das gras so beim kauf
der liegenschaft keine glückliche hand
gehabt hatte das ganze sei ein drama
errichter ebene labyrinth von
prozessrechtlichen geologischer
psychologische frage wo fast immer zu
lösen ist aber halt den schaden hat muss
bewiesen wäre der schaden verursacht das
ist allgemeine regel vom zuviel zeit
buch und in dem moment oder schaden vom
nachbargrundstück und nur stur im
prinzip im nachbargrundstück linie der
von aktiv werden und das wiederum musste
das gericht überhaupt erst erlaube und
da ist letztlich der problematik ich
will dass am schluss am schluss für die
ganze geschichte gerechtigkeit geschafft
wird
[Musik]
nein der garten ist kein ort des
friedens wenn man glaubt das böse wohnen
nebenan
[Musik]
es gibt solche die sich am kran eines
hahns stören
andere ertragen es nicht wenn kühe
grenzen verletzten pannen werden gefällt
weil nadeln aufs falsche grundstück
fallen und ein bauprojekt kann einen
regelrechten kleinkrieg auslösen
wer grenzen überschreitet und um jeden
preis recht haben will
provoziert streit sei es im kleinen
garten oder in der großen welt
[Musik]
dort wurde präsentiert von toyota hybrid
cloud keine steckdose und wird trotzdem
elektrisch